Netflix combines the comedic forces of
Jeff Ross and Dave Attell I don't know
why it's not Dave Attell than Jeff Ross
filmed Comedy Cellar this series fell
taketh be sure zingers audience wrote
they're already bumping Mike's celebrity
cameos Mike bumps watch all three
episodes of bumping Mike's go see Dave
Attell at Caroline's on Broadway in New
York City December 27 through the 30th
get tickets at Caroline's dot-com by the
way we have fritzy who is our resident
comedian I heard and he did Caroline's
really ever stretch the code comedian
but I appreciate that
Wow that's where you humble Richie where
are you stand up he looks like a
comedian he does I could have picked him
out of a lineup
okay size with six jokes and a nice
shirt so Fritzi gets a second time he's
ever done stand-up he goes to Caroline
Wow and then he did the comedy store in
LA after that now not that he earned it
definitely not very blue no Sandler
helped him get in to the comedy store he
won't be back and then Caroline's what
was Sandler's recommendation to you like
hey see like hey I know this guy he's
never done comedy can you give me a shot
yeah that's pretty much I went dad's
really good with a computer and sports
and he wears a headphone for no reason
okay so he did Caroline's and you guys
have all had these moments where there's
crickets no one so they don't know him
and nobody's laughing
maybe that's the sport fritz he should
cover crickets he got roughed up he got
roughed up but but uh I like it you guys
know what that feelings like we haven't
done it and I give him credit but after
a while I like I don't know if I should
shut him down now like when do when do
you know when you're not Jeff Garlin
came on and he was livid that Fritzi
said he's dabbling in comedy and Jeff
Garlin said you have to do a mandatory
or a minimum of 500
and up before you're any good well I'm
gonna say it right now I don't know you
but I do know this that you should live
the dream and the cool thing about your
man fritzy is that he's already dressed
for his next gig running a bowling alley
the shoes is supposed to smell that way
[Laughter]
so when you guys decided to date dresses
like he can't afford a hotel room three
jackets on right now yeah what is the
deal you got like a winter hat and then
well this is my comedy outfit and this
is my I also am a fisherman ready to go
fishing but when you guys decided to do
this how often did you guys perform
together well it was very much like a
hobby for a long time yeah we were like
both have done our own things Geoff is a
roast guys done tons of TV he's great
headliner I'm a headliner you know we're
out on the road and when we come to the
New York together when you see other
comics together it's like so much fun
cuz usually on the road alone so you
know I'd be on stage I see Jeff I bring
him on and we just like go at each other
we'd work the crowd and it was a lot of
fun and I just saw it as that but Jeff
of course he's got the long game you
know and I'm it so he's like you know
this is it this is a show and he can
take you through the rest of it from
there I started begging Dave to like go
on tour with me because you take these
fish out of water it's really fun and
it's different I always say one plus one
equals three we don't have to perform
together but when we do it's special the
jokes per minute is undeniable
but do you try to if if you crack each
other up
is that enough like it's not about the
audience is it about you two
there definitely is that's a really good
point of like making the other comics
laugh and also like people who work at a
comedy club the the staff getting them
to say hey man I love that joke that is
like like really awesome but we have
like a Fant you know you guys have fans
we have these comedy fans and like the
reaction to the bumping mics is beyond I
think both of our like expectations
there's so many comedy fans out there
and they love
joke so what do you guys like it a
family function I'm friendly and and
generous and nice and Dave's a lot like
this are you are you mean do they expect
you because a lot of times they'll be
like hey be funny right I think we went
through that years ago now it's it's
more about like oh so you know you're
here and you know it's a lot about
traveling I think few people get that
like when you're on the road all the
time you know it's like a lot of time in
airports and you know I would say that
the job of comedy is really getting to
it the shows are really the gravy and in
serve as a family what are your plans
for the holidays Jeff what are you can I
spend a lot more time with my family
they're always backstage at the shows
and yeah like that and when Dave goes to
Thanksgiving his whole family dresses
like that and holds microphones Jeff is
really good like Jeff is like we all
you're on the road and to be honest it's
like I ever knew this guy had so much
family because we'd be like in I don't
know Lake Tahoe and all son like a
second cousin of a third aunt would show
up it was like it was like a 23 with me
commercial whatever that is but it was
like look who it is you know these
people would come up and they they
really Jeff is like such a he's such a
prince to all of them so I think it's
cool and it's been a big year for all of
us Jeff just got a new house and it's
your dream house right yeah a
one-bedroom two kitchens earlier didn't
you have a line about ketchup all right
yeah now what we do have the Chocobo
says my favorite drink is because I'm a
mustard guy
the research I'm sorry but the but
you'll get this because like you know
we're old now like there's no real party
after the show there's no crazy you know
I don't know if you know this for its
but it's not a one you know endless
party you know you don't have groupies
no it does not go that way we have an
iron body we have Groupon II yeah you
give a Groupon and you have to sleep
with you guys I've gotten lots of waves
from a mega bus but let me let me let me
tell you this we go out after the show
especially casino shows and we just hit
like the steakhouse and like it is crazy
like honestly like we just go we go to
town you know that's like our party will
bring out some people and we'll just
like eat and eat meat so pretty you in
for that kind of I am all in with that
there you go so you're already halfway
there I love it as a comic and I think
that's awesome how about your um your
mood because I don't it feels like like
don't go there don't go there because
whilst he's very negative I know that
are positive where the friction happens
right you have a smile but it feels like
it's not really a smile what do you mean
like you're waiting like your detonates
guy yeah like yeah I smile waiting for
his head and then all of a sudden then
you're bringing the hammer where is Dave
I sort of expect him to bring the hammer
right I'm tough love I don't know what
he is Velvet machete you know yeah but I
think that offsets it you know like one
of my favorites was back in the day
you'd see like Jack Benny do these kind
of like off-color jokes and then he'd
play violin and soften it up I'm like
I'm like Dave's violin have you ever
truly heard each other's feelings
you know to be honest like I know a lot
of III think we live in a very sensitive
world in a very trigger word world that
like we we I think funny always wins and
with us especially I think that we give
each other many many passes on that kind
of stuff because we're both looking for
jokes a lot of it is riffing so it's
like is it gonna work every time
probably not but with the audience
sometimes I feel like alright maybe we
took it too far but I'll see
one thing about Jeff he is fearless he
really runs at the stuff and I and I
love that about him I mean look at that
shirt that is definitely courage the guy
who's dressed for today and tomorrow I
always wanted that when you see somebody
and you go what's this shirt you decided
not to wear Wow where'd you see what I
have to deal with that's rough you
really want this life so there's no area
that to know goes it's just like an
umpire during a snow delay that's so
crazy just cuz it looks like a bouncer
at a candy store
I've actually would love that but
they're the element of roasting somebody
yes have you ever been roasted yes I had
you you wrote some jokes for Rich Eisen
uh-huh 15 not that long but I remember
10 years ago and Eisen like I could tell
cuz he wants to be a stand-up comedian
in a way he is and and all of a sudden
he came out of the gate and I was like
okay he he was told you got to establish
where you where you're going with the
roast right out of the gate but when you
roast have you ever had you ever made
somebody cry there's one famous roast at
the Friars Club it's not on TV or
anything where the actor who I adore
Danny Aiello
the reviews for his show dela Ventura
had just hit and Richard Belzer started
reading the reviews they come out that
morning and that kind of softened up
Danny so that when I came up and did the
actual jokes about the show I said your
acting was so over the top they should
have called the show a stellar venture
crying during his rebuttal and he said
afterwards it's because he missed his
dad the way he missed the script
rewrites is what he missed for Delavan
Shura
you know people it's a flood of emotions
one time I roasted Jerry Lewis and he
had a heart attack on the way home so I
promised myself I was never I would
never roast another person over 80
did you roast Justin Bieber I did how
did that go that one could have been a
three-part miniseries really that was
one of the greatest ever but it almost
helped him oh yeah because he laughed at
himself he had gotten all this negative
publicity and he took it you know he
took old he took the bullet well the
lesson with Justin's roast is it was his
idea this rarely happens but he
volunteered he called up us at Comedy
Central and said I need I want to be
roasted and he had his heart but it he
really called his friends and made it
great and it did give him a reboot he
needed sort of a reboot in the public
consciousness and it was great
he had a big hit record after that do
you always have a black cloud over you
Dave when you yeah story three times but
do you want to have that dark cloud over
you I do find that there's more I mean
Jeff's absolutely right I am the
negative force in the are you ever in a
good mood
III I feel like a sense of relief like
when we we did this incredibly long
shoot it was very hot in August at the
Village Underground which is a great
club but it's so hot and our director
Andrew who is just like one of the best
guys like he saw like you know he saw
that he saw the take it to another level
of like let's go outside and do things
so like we're doing remotes we're doing
the night shoots so it's all in tensing
but then when it was all done I was like
that sense of like ah that's done you
know now I can focus cigarette and you
know have a good time that's whole thing
- is that like you know I was gonna say
for your guy over here knows that you
know you don't think so because I wanted
to give him you know it's the Holly
times I wanted to give him you know some
swag from the bumping Mike you know Tori
is that cool or that's pretty awesome
yeah I guess I mean hadn't really earned
it I think he has I mean don't you have
to be funny no I think he unball these
very high high high what you call it
level
for you on the show I mean like you're
not even at the first console yet
Mission Control you're the guy who goes
out and gets the coffee like we have a
trough and you have a problem if Dave is
happy Dave is happy when he's doing what
he what he loves when he's up there
riffing when people are telling him the
show's funny like to me I think and
he'll get mad at me for outing him but
this is his happy place right now I like
new jokes that's really the thing that
gets me going that's why with Jeff and
people think it's like oh these two of
you up there so it's easier it's way
harder you have to listen you have to
like think quickly and that's what I
love the thrill of it because in comedy
really is the thrill of like the new
joke and the crowd getting it that
really is like that's our you know like
I would say that's our big thing you
know there's sports fans watching us
what we do is like volleying you know my
favorite tennis matches as a kids were
like McEnroe in Connors my dad would
take me and I go that's what we're doing
like one guy might be a little better
like Dave's the best comic in New York
and for me to try to keep up with him is
athletic to me it's almost like a game
we don't keep score
which makes it fun and we don't get on
each other like you asked if we make
each other upset that doesn't really
happen because if he gets a laugh I'm
sharing in that adulation well and
you're a willing partner where you'll
give him dab by bump bumping mics to say
you got me that's his idea pumping at
the end of the jokes I wanted to bump
something else your favorite joke oh wow
that's a good question I love Dave
simple jokes from way back in a day like
you're doing can I do one yeah but don't
you know Dave Dave says I went to
Australia and we help me with it
all right I'll do set me up they'll go
like it's a very long flight Jeff how
long how long a fight is it well when I
landed I called my house I picked up the
phone I got it
okay do you explain jokes cuz fritzy has
a problem where he he tries to explain
the jokes so you'll understand it well
you know what I was gonna say like I
don't know what the time thing is here
but I would like to hear a joke from
Fritzie already I've heard a lot of okay
heard a lot of smoke I want some okay
can you guys put your headphones on I'm
gonna I'm gonna play this was his
opening bit does this Dave Dave have
headphones I don't think Dave understood
English like now I look like one of my
chefs best put down okay okay this is
this is this is the opening line at
Caroline's okay okay so here's Todd
Fred's the show is bumping mics on
Netflix with Dave Attell and Jeff Ross
here we go so I'm at a sporting event
the other night and at least three
different people come over to me asking
if I'm sitting in their seats so I don't
know if it's a few guys ever deal with
this if you go to a concert of sporting
events how difficult is to [ __ ] seats
and concert or a sporting event think
about it it's got all the information
you need right there on the ticket
section row seat number section row see
number it's really really not that
complicated I've got these people coming
over to me and saying I think we're in
the same thing not only they not in my
seats they're all the way on the other
side of they really couldn't have been
further from where I'm at so I don't
understand section row seat let's let's
get it together
did you really corner the usher market
that was the first joke out okay that's
the entire bit I feel like you're still
in the audience it's kind of like when
you get on a plane and they tell you all
that information you're not gonna listen
to it because I said there's obsolete
observational humor but you have to have
humor and and he had the observation yes
you're leaving out stage presence and a
clean shirt that's being too tough on
him I mean honestly what kind of crowd
was it that night
cuz you know remember the crowds an
important part of every joke was it a
monday night monday night monday night
tourist yeah see the people that fritzy
was booked ended with though the person
right before him and the person
right after him crushed okay so what do
you think fritzy are you gonna keep that
joke or are you gonna let it go I let it
go immediately because I said that at
Caroline's but I did not use it at the
say that's see right away you're like
two years ahead of most guys who start
they're like you know was it me was the
crowd and then you hold on to these you
know these like stinkers you know well
she's really just like barium in the
cornfield unless I had some kind of
better ending which you guys would do
much better than me as far as turns out
that I was in the wrong seat all along
with one of the suggestions no really
now now that joke doesn't need more
setup that's a tell my mom over the
phone how to unplug the toaster stay in
the moment fritzy and and like like Dave
like Dave that outfit makes a statement
what is it I know how to delete a hard
drive what is your favorite Jef joke
well I'm gonna say one right now what
the headphones on he looks like a triple
stuffed Oreo 1039 yeah funny until like
10:30 9 p.m. here's the joke that I love
about Jeff that he doesn't do anymore
which is the I don't know the setup but
uh the punchline is enough with the
bread already what if I used to be a
poem that my my dad used to say to my
mom the classic and then we your eyes
are like open seas blue from coast to
coast your heart like it's a big love
poem and then at the end he goes but
enough with the bread already that's my
favorite
your smile blooms like a bright summer
flower your heart is like a rain shower
so how come your ass looks like a truck
then my mom would write one back to my
dad called put a shirt on you're scaring
the children away you know the one where
I
you saw Angela Lansbury oh yeah that was
just the other day I was walking around
downtown I saw it you never know what
you're gonna see in New York I saw
Angela Lansbury in an antique shop
twelve hundred bucks got a good sense of
humor even though he dresses like a
substitute teacher that never got
promoted to regular about 15 minutes in
and I took a shot I was I thought it'd
be a little bit earlier a lot of people
don't bother to wear their Christmas
sweaters from the 1990s it's that time
in the year he's keeping the headphones
on just to keep warm Jeff the face the
face is gonna look better when the
swelling goes down
[Laughter]
yeah there you go that's all I got as
anybody ever said you are okay I'm
curious what about you Dave I don't know
we both kind of look like a deleted
scene from the movie taken we're not
really we're not GQ material no it's
what's really funny is that uh you know
comedy has never been been hotter and
stuff like that he was like when I say
it's but I I like to think that I'm
towards the end of it instead at the
beginning of it
and it's really the most fun I've ever
had is in the last couple of years just
like riffing with Jeff working on the
road these young comics coming up you
know seeing them you know do this stuff
even Fritz over here it takes a lot of
you know you know it takes it takes some
really big you know balls to do comedy
so did I give you a lot of credit man I
really do bumping mics on Netflix
combines this is where we wrap up I love
it yeah this is my favorite part
okay bumping mics on Netflix combines
the comedic forces of Jeff Ross and Dave
Attell or Dave Attell and Jeff Ross no
it's Jeff Ross and Dave Attell I don't
know ask your lawyer did you print up
the shirts already yeah yeah we did
already I really want to get one there
fritzy here man I want you to be part of
the team I would love that
that's cool Mike
humming like hats and cuz you're like a
comic you get a discount 15 bucks it
works that works they filmed it at the
Comedy Cellar and the series features
zingers audience rows
celebrity cameo so you got Bruce Willis
a drunk Paul Rudd Amy Schumer Saget
Gilbert Godfried Michael che there's
just so many great comics that drop by
and I have to say you know Michelle wolf
all these great people came by Hasan
Minhaj I mean like it was so much fun to
have them all on stage and that was
another like Jeff thing where it's just
like let's let's bring some you know
like friends up and like and like talk
to them and have fun with them and you
know but I'd say of my of all the
favorites Gilbert really completed it
and if you're over a certain generation
you know how funny this guy is you know
what you'll find out you had a line
about a roast and then you had somebody
up there with you they say it looks like
you've already been roasted yeah Wow
well shut out - Izzy del Toro Wow I was
a flight instructor for the military
he's a wounded veteran barely wounded
veteran and we had met him along the way
at the Bob Woodruff foundation gala that
we did in San Francisco and he came on
stage this guy wanted to get roasted
he's he's a very brave dude severely
burned he has an amazing sense of humor
and I'll admit it we kind of barked we
weren't sure where to go with it and
then he came to our show in New York
when the cameras were rolling and like
I'm giving you guys a second chance
we're doubling down right now and of
course like we started letting the jokes
roll and the audience was uncomfortable
for a second but then we kind of broke
the ice and I congratulated him on
starring in all those Deadpool movie and
he laughed and the audience laughed and
then of course he got the last laugh as
he said uh standing between you two guys
I feel like George Clooney he's super
funny guy he is a Jeff and I both done
like USO tours and and I'll tell you one
thing the best crowd I can say for me
personally I've ever had is the troops
they are so much fun and you know
especially deployed when you go over to
Afghanistan Iraq and you just see like
the they're so excited it really it
makes you feel like you know you're on
this level of show
is your way at the top and it really so
it's a humbling honor to do it you can
watch all three episodes of bumping mics
you can see Dave Attell at Caroline's on
Broadway that'll be December 27 through
the 30th you're calming down buddy
you're gonna win it back I'm gonna get
it back well you're definitely am if he
shows up he's coming on no you're coming
obviously you don't want that we're
gonna make that make him that look even
that much more funny than we already
know is what I totally bomb no dude I'm
bringing you up you two do it we're
gonna work it together man you are
[ __ ] bag revant you I'll be right
behind you you'll be the one who sees me
you're a good person you can get tickets
at Caroline's dot-com it's Netflix it's
bumping mics with Dave Attell and Jeff
Ross thanks for having thank you guys
we're fun then thanks yeah dude let's
pump it out all right here we go for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]